uh dorsa so has there been actually any
any reaction from Iran
today there hasn't been any official
reaction from Iranian government
spokesperson or any other high ranking
officials here in the capital tan but I
I think it's going to come very soon
this is going to be seen as a huge
victory for not only the Palestinian uh
cause but also for the Iranian uh
government and system which has been
behind the Palestinian cause since the
very uh beginning of the formation of
the state of Israel and the Islamic
revolution of 1979 we've heard from the
Iranian supreme leader Ayatollah Ali
last Tuesday where he h spoke at length
about the uh plight of the Palestinian
people and I think his words are very
very um reflective of the events we've
seen on fold today in Gaza and in uh
Israel as well com
said that they are um the countries that
were establishing ties with Israel are
betting on a losing horse he also said
that the Palestinian movement is more uh
alive than it has ever been during the
past 70 to 80 years and that the
movement will achieve its goals uh he
also has said that uh Israel is a cancer
that needs to be eradicated at the hands
of the Palestinian people and the
resistance forces in the region I think
it's important to highlight Iran has
always supported uh groups such as
Islamic Jihad and Hamas not only when it
comes to the um belief uh ideological
belief that they have about their own
existence in in Palestine but also when
it comes to supplying them with whatever
they need now unofficially they've never
admitted that they Supply weapons or
funding to those groups but it is
believed that that is usually uh what
happens uh especially as well to groups
like um Hezbollah in Lebanon as well so
there is a very strong relationship
between Iran and those groups uh in
Palestine and this is going to be seen
as a victory for not only the
Palestinian um resistant movement but
also for the Iranian officials I guess
the question is how much more support
are they willing to give is it just
going to be words or is there going to
be action I mean we've actually heard a
call for arms from the alassan Brigade
this morning uh you know what what is
going to be the thinking in Iran about
that well uh usually when Iran unveils
just to give you an idea a new missile
of any kind they always make a point uh
to reference how long their missiles
would take to reach Tel Aviv from tan
the last time we saw this happen was in
June when Iran unveiled its first ever
Hypersonic ballistic missile uh and uh
they said that that it would take six
minutes for it to reach Tel Aviv from
tan a warning to Israel that they have
uh said over and over again with each
unveiling of these missiles now
officially Iran has not admitted that
they are selling or providing these uh
missiles to uh the groups the resistance
groups in uh Palestine but uh I think uh
many believe that that is the case
whether or not they'll publicly admit it
will remain to be seen there is a United
Nations security Council uh resolution
that is due to be lifted on October 18th
where any limitation on Iran selling its
uh Advanced missile technology and
Military technology to any country uh is
going to be lifted completely so they
will not have any restrictions whether
that will be a factor in uh Iranian
officials admitting that they're selling
their U missiles to uh groups in uh
Palestine uh we'll have to see but just
to give you an idea the number of
missiles that we saw launched today from
Gaza 2,200 of them about just about uh
is a huge number in comparison to uh the
last war the Gaza War we saw in 2014
where that lasted for 50 days and during
the 50 days we saw about uh 4,500 or so
uh Rockets being launched by the
resistant movements uh in Gaza so there
is a huge increase in the number of uh
missiles that they have in their Arsenal
and it's going to be a very important
question that the International
Community will certainly have for
Iranian officials whether or not they've
been providing it and whether or not
they will admit to it or not but one
thing is certain when it comes to
providing support to the Palestinian
people from the very top of the system
here from the supreme leader himself Ali
k h they he has said over and over again
that they Iranians will do anything they
can to help their resistance and to free
the Palestinian people and to get rid of
the occupiers in um their on their land
now what that means they never specify
but we'll have to wait and see tosa
Jabari there first in tan